it's great to welcome to the program
today David Cortright who is a
University of North Florida historian
and addiction expert also author of the
book the age of addiction how bad habits
became big business so great to have you
on today I appreciate your time I'll
David it's great to be here so let's
start with maybe just defining some of
the terms we're using when we talk about
addiction are we talking about it in a
in a sort of way that more approximates
what the medical community sees as
addiction or are we talking about
something else that maybe is more
related to cultural norms or
expectations or social norms what do we
mean by addiction in this sense actually
we're talking about both we're talking
about addiction in a medical sense and
we're also talking about the social fact
of addiction that more and more people
are describing more and more things as
being addictive you know and in many
ways the big question is whether that's
hype or whether there really is
something medical and in a public health
way very important about these novel
forms of addiction the one area that
probably immediately comes to people's
minds when we talk about the business of
addiction is social media and
smartphones and these variable rewards
systems that function very much like
like slot machines but you actually are
looking beyond that right I mean you're
looking at other industries as well
right I was actually it was as much a
matter of personal curiosity as anything
I started and work in this field 40
years ago and when I started out if you
put plate award Association game what do
you think of when you think of addiction
people would say heroin or some other
drug and that was pretty much yet now
you could get any answer or any one of
several answers you could get porn you
could get social media you could get
food addiction there are lots and lots
of addictions out there and so the basic
question is what led to such a
proliferation of addictions and what
does it do or have to do with our
economic and social systems so let's
start thinking about that that there's
this term limbic capitalism that you
can we first talk a little bit about
what you mean by that because it's so
key to understanding your perspective
right and so I was looking for a common
denominator and what I found is that
there are in fact many different kinds
of businesses that have a common
strategy and that strategy is to provide
products and services that produce a
quick hit of brain reward and that's
really the key because ultimately most
of their profits come from only a
handful of their customers and they
really depend on those heavy regular
users and at the limit at the extreme I
think it's fair to call those users
addicts and can we apply that to so I
mean I I recently had a conversation
with a caller about the concept of the
American Dream and there was this idea
that you could even go I mean on the one
hand you might have something as
nitty-gritty as the Facebook algorithm
but then on the other hand you could
make the case that the idea of the
American dream of home ownership
sometimes even if it's beyond one's
means of having the latest car and
technology and whatever that can also
generate a form of what some might call
addiction or addiction to consumption
culture or something like that does that
fall under what you're describing or is
that maybe outside of it it's actually
outside of it this is a question I get a
lot is is there something addictive
about capitalism or consumerism itself
and I don't really go there because I
think that that's that's just pushing it
too hard if someone's in the hardware
business and they're competing to sell
you the latest lawnmower or you know new
gutters for your house or whatever they
may resort to advertising you may be
keeping up with the Joneses but that's
not the same thing as an addiction an
addiction is something that involves
loss of control it involves craving
preoccupation and it involves fairly
serious harms to both yourself your
family and to society and so I I to me
that's not garden-variety consumerism
but there is a species of consumerism
which is involved with these very
fast-acting brain rewarding products
that is in a category by itself can you
I want to talk about what's happening in
the brain when when the social media
dopamine hits are happening but before
we do that can you give us a couple of
other examples that maybe are less
obvious one so you said you know maybe
the lawnmower sales is not but the
social media is what are some other
examples that do fall under the the
purview of what you're describing well
they're surprising some of them anyway
or they were surprising to me so there's
in fact a large body of medical
literature on tanning salons as a kind
of behavioral addiction there are people
who actually find the ultraviolet
radiation and the ritual brain rewarding
to the point that they they just can't
break it off and they end up doing
themselves fairly serious harm most
obvious harm being increased risk of
skin cancer so yeah there are other
other kinds of addictive behaviors out
there so let's talk a little bit now
about the the dopamine release that that
exists with a lot of these variable
reward systems so as I understand it you
have a Facebook account email falls
under this notifications on Instagram
whatever the case may be you don't know
at any particular point in time when you
access your account whether you will
have notifications or likes or comments
or interesting posts from someone and
it's the fact that the reward is
unpredictable that makes you seek it out
more often because the reward is
sometimes maybe more exciting than other
times and that is what generates a lot
of that repeated action is that more or
less the way we should understand it and
what's happening in the brain when that
takes place
well technically what's happening in the
brain is a burst release of dopamine you
get a little dopamine hit when you get
alike in the same way that if you hit a
small jackpot on a digital gambling
machine in Las Vegas that's rewarding
too in fact a simple way to think about
this is we're all walking around when
we're walking
one of these we're all walking around
with a little slot machine in our hands
and you're right you don't know what's
going to come across the screen and a
lot of it is rewarding and the fact that
it's variable reinforcement also is a
big part of it how do we consider the
types of or I guess before we even get
to that I mean so so you've identified
the this issue and others have as well
and depending on ones either worldview
or sensibilities or other factors they
might say this is something that needs
to be quote solved or fixed in some way
others might say no this is going to
sort of naturally work itself out it's
not not really the problem that some are
describing it to be question one is is
this a problem that requires fixing in
your mind and if so what are the types
of solutions that we should be looking
at well certainly there are harms that
stem from addictive behavior and so even
something as as seemingly innocuous as
spending too much time on your
smartphone becomes a different matter if
you're doing it while you're driving so
people really do lose their lives
because of distracted driving that's a
problem and that requires I think some
kind of a policy response but what you
have is a whole array of possible
responses everything from education all
the way to at the other extreme
prohibition no no nobody's arguing or at
least I'm not arguing for the
prohibition of smartphones or social
media but I think there are real
questions of regulation that do arise
from these kinds of practices what would
be a form of regulation that would not
be an immediate sort of political
go-nowhere suggestion because you would
have just extraordinary disagreement
from you know the anti nanny-state side
the libertarian side the sceptical of
corporations that there's all these
competing political interest it's hard
for me as someone who's in this stuff
all the time to think about what sort of
regulation might even have a have a
prayer of passing and becoming a reality
well if you're looking at smartphones
and social media privacy regulation
would be a good example I mean this this
would discourage certain kinds of apps
that are basically designed to get
information about you so that the
providers can then sell that invitation
I'm sorry that information to
advertisers and you and they can make a
lot of money for other kinds of
addictive products you have policy
proposals that are relatively
non-controversial like age restrictions
okay so the whole jewel scandal and and
what's happening with vaping is another
really good example of this even the
manufacturers have jumped on board the
let's raise it to age 21 bandwagon
generally speaking anything that poses a
threat or a perceived threat to youth is
most likely to prompt a strong policy
response that that's kind of the the
ultimate hot button here is it it
endangers the health and well-being of
young people then you tend to get
stronger reactions that have a broader
base of political support there's quite
a bit of scholarship about the perils of
Vice taxes and the idea that they can
and even going further than taxing vices
actually banning vices can make the make
it even more appealing to try to access
or avail oneself of whatever it is that
a law rule or tax is trying to
disincentivize do you think that that is
relevant when we think about the issue
of of limbic capitalism and addicting
technology or we'd really dealing with
kind of a different animal with a
different sort of framework that we
should put around it yeah I I think that
there's a sweet spot when it comes to
taxation I don't know if the fact of
taxation necessarily is an inducement to
using these products but sometimes
governments will tax a product for the
sake of revenue which by the way is one
of the the main barriers to anti-vice
policies is that governments have a
stake in the revenue streams as well as
private corporations sure I mean lottery
tickets her great example of that all
you can you can think of many others but
you can tax it at a level that provides
revenue or you can tax it really high so
that it's a quasi prohibition and in
many states in the United States
cigarettes for example are taxed at such
a high rate that it's virtually a
prohibition or for many people it's a
kind of prohibition because they're so
expensive
um I think there's a sweet spot in
between or you can tax things in a way
that you are discouraging the use of a
product but you're not taxing them at
such a rate that what you do is simply
create another black market in the
products which for example has happened
with cannabis in many states there's
still a huge black market in cannabis
largely because the state taxes are so
high can you talk a little bit about so
that there will be there will be people
who watch this interview or listen to
The Sitter view and they'll say okay
there are new ways in which companies
are now taking advantage of of this
understanding of how the brain works
that are very notable to us like social
media but this is not new in the sense
that companies really have had an
understanding of this and have been
taking advantage of it for a long time
question one is do you agree that this
has been going on in some form for a
long time but then part two of the
question is is there something has a
line been crossed in some way that it is
now materially different than what it
was before yes
the the book is a history and we've had
addictions as part of the human
condition for a long long time and we've
been developing new pleasures and
blending pleasures and all of that but
it's only in the last 400 years or so
that the thing really took off with
transatlantic Commerce with the
development of plantation agriculture
industrialization mass marketing the
rise of cities and then to that I would
add that it's been in only in the last
30 years or so that we've reached the
point or people have become so
sophisticated about these products that
they're actually designing products in a
way to maximize their addictive
potential so in other words there was
Commerce in addictive products there was
mass production of addictive products
there were lots of hooks out there in
the consumer waters but now we figured
out how to sharpen those hooks to some
degree I know that you you know you made
clear that you're not an anti-capitalist
and neither am i but to some degree it
does seem as though a lot of the
substance of the addictive nature of
some of these platforms is connected to
consumer culture in a way that we can't
really divorce from the economic system
that we have and I'm trying to find the
right way to sort of frame the question
on the one hand you don't have to be
anti-capitalist
to offer a strong critique and solutions
to the problem you identify at the same
time there seems to be something about
the current flavor of capitalism that's
predominant that can't really be
divorced from the problem you identify
yeah one way to think about that is we
do live in a culture of consumption but
there's consumption and there's
excessive consumption and then at the
far extreme there's addiction I mean I
really like to think of addiction as the
endpoint the harmful endpoint of one of
several spectra of consumption and if
you think of it in those terms you don't
have to indict the whole system of
consumer capitalism to realize that
there are some products and practices
that are particularly harmful and I
think particularly call out for
regulation vaping again coming to mind
as an example yeah I mean I don't know I
we don't have to go completely off into
vaping but here in Massachusetts there's
been this four month a sort of
moratorium while the causes of some of
the vaping related injuries are being
investigated and that seems to be a
particularly complex one because on the
one hand you have the vaping products
themselves and the harm that they're
causing but then you also have what some
are pointing out is a bit of an
incongruence behind between vaping law
cannabis law and cigarette and alcohol
law and sometimes it seems as though the
I mean I'm curious whether you have a
particular take on what you think should
be done as far as the vaping products
are concerned well vaping products fall
into a special category of
toxic products that are enormous ly
beneficial when used properly another
classic example would be prescription
opioids which is also a huge issue in
Massachusetts
these are life-saving drugs when used
properly when you're treating people
after surgery or people have been
traumatized or people who are at the end
of life you know these are valuable and
legitimate commodities on the other hand
you can look at what's happened over the
last 25 or 30 years and realized that
there were industries that over promoted
and over supplied these same products in
a way that was not good for the public
health so it's really a two-edged sword
in the problem of regulation for these
products in particular are these kinds
of products is how do you get the
maximum medical benefit out of them in
the case of vaping obviously to harm
reduction for confirmed smokers well all
at the same time preventing the harms
which would be nicotine addiction for
young smokers we've been speaking with
David Cortright who is a University of
North Florida historian and addiction
expert much of what we've been
discussing is outlined in more detail in
the book the age of addiction how bad
habits became big business david's such
a pleasure having you on and i really
appreciate your time today
Oh David again it's been great to be
with you